Bienvenidos a la entrevista con Franz 24
hoy nos encontramos con la vise primera
ministra de Ucrania Irina beren Muchas
gracias por estar hoy con nosotros
Gracias
dice primera ministra
Ucrania firmó recientemente un decreto
en el que
declaró la imposibilidad de negociar
computing cuán lejos está la posibilidad
de la reactivación de un diálogo y
cuáles son las condiciones de Ucrania
para que este diálogo se reinicie
para el gobierno con diplomático
en este momento nuestros mejores
negociadores y diplomáticos son los
soldados están eliminando al enemigo así
negocian Esta es la única alternativa
que tenemos hoy el kremlin y Rusia no
nos han dejado otra opción han visto y
oído lo que su líder un criminal como
Putin dice y hace está preparándose para
una gran guerra es lo que ha dicho por
eso necesitamos las armas y las
necesitamos rápido eso le quitará la a
Rusia de atacarnos y de atacar a otros
países y llevar adelante una agresiva
guerra en el mundo
Entonces no tenemos que esperarnos que
Ucrania se siente a negociar con Rusia
en un corto plazo de tiempo
tenemos luego
no es posible en este momento por qué es
imposible
Rusia no quiere la paz Rusia no quiere
remover su ejército y sus armas de
Ucrania Rusia intenta aterrorizarnos y
amenaza las democracias del mundo lo ha
hecho por ejemplo con moldavia y Polonia
siguen preparándose para una guerra de
Gran escala es la razón por la que
cualquier negociación está abocada al
fracaso por eso no participaremos en
negociación alguna como hace resultado
Entonces ustedes no tienen ninguna
condición en este momento que le
pondrían a Rusia para reactivar el
diálogo
La Única condición es que Rusia retire
sus tropas y armas de nuestro territorio
luego se podrá hablar de diálogo hasta
ese momento ninguna negociación tendrá
sentido alguno Rusia está matando
nuestros civiles dañando nuestras
infraestructuras eléctricas está
intentando destruirnos como nación la
única alternativa es vencerles y solo
tenemos una oportunidad de luchar y
ganar
cuando dice territorio de Ucrania se
refiere a todo el territorio
sin o solo el territorio ocupado después
del 24 de febrero del año pasado
si territorio
todo el territorio no hay ni una
posibilidad de que Rusia se quede ni tan
solo con un metro de nuestra tierra
independiente esto incluye a crimea doña
ex y todo el territorio de las fronteras
reconocidas por los acuerdos de 1991
tenemos que esperarnos una escalada de
las hostilidades
la escalada continúa desde hace un año
desde el 24 de febrero del año pasado
como recordará la guerra empezó en 2014
con la ocupación de crimea el 24 de
febrero pasado vimos lo que ocurre
cuando no se sanciona Rusia Rusia está
poniendo presión al mundo los chantajea
a través de su energía lo chantaje con
sus armas nucleares destruye el medio
ambiente y continúa su escalada nosotros
nos hemos preparado para cualquier
desarrollo de la situación actual Rusia
no puede derrotarnos porque estamos
luchando por nuestra tierra nuestros
valores y nuestra verdad
Estados Unidos Europa han dado dinero
fondos para la administración ucraniana
y también para el ejército ucraniano
está satisfecha del apoyo que ha
recibido Ucrania hasta el momento
agradecemos todo lo que están haciendo
Estados Unidos Francia España y todas
las demás naciones democráticas y las
sociedades del mundo libre
damos las gracias por cada dólar cada
centavo y cada cartucho de combate que
hemos recibido porque de verdad lo
necesitamos enormemente
Rusia tiene más recursos que nosotros y
los está usando por eso hemos tenido que
pedir la ayuda de nuestros aliados
tenemos que ganar esta guerra Esta es
una inversión para la seguridad del
mundo Cada nación que ayuda a Ucrania
está ayudándose a sí misma
hace un año Putin ordenó de invadir
Ucrania y algunos partidos políticos
desde entonces han sido prohibidos la
ley Marcial
está en vigor es difícil administrar una
democracia en guerra
Newton de Bosco
democrática desarrollada
No no es difícil solo parece así parece
que ahora con la guerra nuestra
democracia está bajo amenaza pero
nosotros estamos luchando por nuestra
democracia democracia es lo que queremos
queremos que nuestra gente pueda elegir
a sus gobiernos queremos que nuestra
gente pueda ejercitar su derecho a
expresarse y que todos tengan los
derechos y la responsabilidades escritas
en nuestra Constitución nuestra
democracia se está fortaleciendo con
esta guerra Y esta es la única manera
con la que podemos ganar mire yo trabajo
en cosas muy prácticas como la
asistencia humanitaria y le hago un
ejemplo hay civiles en bahmud que están
en gravísimo riesgo y nos gustaría
evacuarles pero la ley no nos permite ni
obligarlos a irse ni tampoco evacuar a
sus niños sin el consentimiento escrito
de sus padres así funciona nuestra
democracia tuvo
desarrollo
le preocupa la corrupción en Ucrania
Por supuesto porque la corrupción mata
la confianza la confianza de la gente en
los gobiernos especialmente en la
justicia en las autoridades que tienen
que proteger los derechos de las
personas la corrupción también es una
terrible arma para el enemigo no debería
existir durante la Guerra nuestro país
Confía en nosotros saben por lo que
estamos luchando si no lucháramos contra
la corrupción perderíamos la confianza
de la gente y luego del país
usted también es responsable de los
territorios ocupados Cuáles son en este
momento las situaciones más dramáticas y
tienen acceso a las zonas
ocupadas por Rusia
en el territorio
las peores situaciones están vinculadas
a la situación de seguridad
habrá visto que esta semana han atacado
gerson y hubo 21 heridos eran todos
civiles lo mismo ha ocurrido también en
algunas zonas retomadas en la provincia
de harquez sobre el acceso a las zonas
ocupadas no no tenemos ese acceso ni yo
ni mis colaboradores
Cuántos civiles han sido evacuados de
los territorios ocupados hasta el día de
hoy y cuántos
prisioneros han sido intercambiados en
los intercambios que se hacen con con
Rusia
desde el 24 de febrero nos arreglamos
para evacuar con corredores humanitarios
unas 550.000 personas
han sido evacuadas todas civiles en
cuanto a los intercambios de prisioneros
sólo puedo decir la cifra total de los
que se intercambiaron cuando yo estaba a
cargo fueron 408 pero centenares de
nuestros civiles siguen en prisiones
rusas
qué ocurre cuando ustedes
retoman el control de una zona
anteriormente ocupada por Rusia que pasa
con esas personas que son acusadas de
colaborar
les arrestan qué ocurre con ellas
individual
[Música]
depende cada caso se estudia
individualmente Si una persona es
culpable o no eso lo decide la justicia
somos un país democrático y solo un juez
puede decir si una persona es un
colaboracionista sin duda tenemos casos
de personas que han colaborado en las
zonas retomadas pero en cualquier caso
la justicia decide creo que no
deberíamos castigarles con mucha dureza
porque el principal responsable de lo
que ha ocurrido es Rusia ellos vinieron
y ocuparon nuestro territorio forzaron
nuestra gente a ser refugiados aquí el
criminal es Rusia
se está preparando para
una guerra
muy larga
y cómo se imagina su país cuando la
guerra acaba
muy
ritmo
estamos preparándonos para cualquier
desarrollo pero realmente Esperamos que
el apoyo que viene de nuestros aliados
nos ayude y que esta guerra termine en
2023 una vez hayamos ganado el proceso
de reconstrucción será largo pero
necesitamos devolver vida a nuestra
gente que ha sufrido tanto con graves
repercusiones mentales también millones
de personas se fueron de este país y
tenemos que hacer que regresen para que
nuestro país vuelva a sonreír
mostró
Muchísimas gracias
Vice primera ministra por esta
entrevista y suerte con su trabajo
gracias por su trabajo y la posibilidad
de hablar con su audiencia